oh my god it's happening far to my Q&A
finally after what has been eight nine
months I think a child could have been
conceived and born in the time that it
took for me to do part one to now part
two so I apologize for that I am sorry
I'm the worst at time management but
that's just me I'm sorry if like the
chairs on Klunk Klunk Klunk are the
leathers I just it's cool looking and so
if it makes clunky weird sounds
apologize we got new scenery though we
got like evil Darth Vader and Scarlet
Spider and Metal Gear Rex and Naked
Snake with his box and that's cool
though alright this is officially it's
part two now we have new settings but
it's like the same location but new
so let's get on this here are the
questions like half of these questions
are going to be from part one that I
didn't get to so they're gonna be
carryovers from with last march and the
other half is gonna be on twitter at
jeremy John's shameless plug and I
said hey I'm doing another Q&A so what
questions you want to ask so this is
from that so let's start I've seen older
reviews where you used to have an
earring what made you wear it what made
you take it off when I was graduating
high school I told her one also you know
I'm gonna get an earring they're like is
really funny and no you're not so at
that point I had to get it it was just
like they dared me to get it I said no
you won't so I got an earring in so I
just kept it and then one day I was like
trying to outgrew it so that's what
happens when you grow up I guess you
take your earring out for such a
perceptive and knowledgeable person on
movies have you ever wanted to focus on
writing film yeah when I was like 19
years old maybe 20 my friends and I came
up with a couple of ideas and a couple
of scripts and now look I still have the
scripts and looking back at it I was
like this isn't good I'm so glad I
didn't make this it's not good it's
endearing because it's one of those
things where I did but it's not great we
did come up with a really cool concept
for a Castlevania movie though we like
before Heath Ledger was Heath Ledger we
came up with Heath Ledger was gonna be
the Belmont and it was gonna have Alba
card we came up with not gonna lie this
pretty good idea I hope they do that I
never scripted it though I feel like I'm
one of those people I can come up with
good ideas and really imaginative ideas
but it takes a different kind of person
to put them into a script or a novel or
something like that so it would be like
a collaborative effort if I were to ever
come up with a story hey Jeremy you owe
me $12.50 that movie was no alcohol
required at best not awesome tacular
this is
from Captain America the Winter Soldier
so I imagine this person is talking
about Captain America the Winter Soldier
however if it is a good time to alcohol
required you got your money's worth so I
don't know you anything and even if you
didn't get your money's worth I still
wouldn't owe you anything now learn to
take my opinion for what it is which is
why don't you do TV show reviews I do
some TV show videos or sometimes it's a
review for the series sometimes when a
series starts I'll do a video on it
sometimes when there's a big event like
in Game of Thrones we'll do a video on
it but ultimately I can't do a video on
everything for every series that exists
ever I mean you gotta keep entertainment
fun and still do videos on things it's
really it's a tough line to walk
ultimately what I don't want to happen
is for Game of Thrones to come on and
then I'm like uh I don't want Game
eternal I don't want to do a video on
Game of Thrones dammit I just uh I wish
Game of Thrones is coming on tomorrow
because I don't want to do a video today
I don't want that to happen ever I want
to keep things fun I want to keep it for
myself so I don't always do a review on
every episode of shows or every show
that I watch you just try to walk the
line try to give you guys what I can but
ultimately I'm a one-man show here how
do you stay so energized throughout your
whole review do you take breaks and grab
an energy bar or something is that why
there are so many cuts there are so many
cuts because I am energized and I do
talk fast and sometimes you make a
slip-up and you want to cut it and just
cutting it just makes it as fast as I
want to be able to talk but taking
breaks now I'd energize and get OD dunk
coffee before I actually do the video
not during if you could join any movies
world what would it be
that's actually really tough because if
you say I want to join the Marvel
Cinematic Universe it doesn't
necessarily mean you're going to be a
Marvel superhero you could be just like
a random civilian running away from the
battle if you if you say you I want to
join Star Wars doesn't mean you're gonna
be a Jedi you might not have the force
you could just be again a civilian but I
think I got it figured out of all the
worlds I would want to be part of Asgard
because I feel like even if I'm a
civilian in Asgard I'm still a god like
I'm more powerful than anyone on earth
so Asgard someone out there is gonna say
oh no it's not true and I'm just gonna
destroy that so give me that don't
I'm actually me on that let me believe
that everyone in Asgard is a god when
you first started doing movie reviews
did you find it easy or difficult and
why when I first started doing this it's
not easy because there's nothing easy
about talking to a camera it's a lens
looking at you and you're talking and
it's
a weird thing there's no easy way to be
like hi to talk normal like you're
talking to a person you have to first
imagine a person and then as you keep
doing it somehow it just gets easier and
you start talking to this camera like
you're talking to you guys out there
like you can feel the people watching
you and so but at first no it's it's
really strange it's no way about it
there's no two ways about it I'm not
gonna be su if you want to start doing
this at first it's gonna be really
weird have you ever tried to be
a comedian like on stage doing
impressions and first of all I'm
glad that you like my impersonations
that I do because I like doing them and
once in a while like wouldn't I might
Matthew McConaughey that I did on my
interstellar review interstellar which
is a movie I actually liked for people
who thought I didn't that was weird
but I was going home and for some odd
reason I I said something in Matthew
McConaughey's voice knows okay I think I
might be able to do that I meant to
shoehorn that into the review so yeah I
but I haven't tried to be a comedian
it's a different thing from talking to a
camera to a crowd that you have to feed
on them and they feed on you it's a very
symbiotic thing and it's different to be
able to collect your thoughts and do
this than be a comedian although by the
time you've done your act a few times I
like to think that you have it down like
clockwork but it is a different I want
there are a few times that I've thought
to myself that I should just go to an
open mic night somewhere and just do a
comedy bit somewhere where no one will
know if I suck ass at it no one will
know that I sucked on stage although
somehow I think it'll get out there but
I've thought about it but I haven't done
it yet we'll see what happens Jeremy
which of your reviews is your favorite I
don't know that I have a favorite review
I have favorite moments within reviews
like my Mass Effect 3 ending and why we
hate it video that's a really good one I
liked that one when I did it I knew that
it was going to be a good it was just it
was well-constructed I thought it's one
of those things where I had a couple
days to really hash it out and think it
out when I do review I watch the movie I
get home I do my review but this one I
could really take my time he's really
hammer it out and I like doing that
other than that there are moments in my
reviews that I actually really enjoy
like just recently I did one where I had
it was a what was it was no it wasn't
weak he was Annabel and I had the two
little demons little cartoon demons
talking to each other
you want to play some destiny and what I
was doing that it was just it was funny
because it was so different than what I
usually do to any review that were it
allows me to do something different than
what I usually do it's it's a good
moment any video what's your favorite
food sushi i love sushi i was wondering
when the movie comes out in 3d or non 3d
which do you usually pick and does
reviewing impact the choice in the
matter thanks I'm gonna call non 3d 2d
for the sake of semantics but those may
be in a dick I'm sorry but ultimately if
a movie comes out in 2d or 3d I will
pick 2d / 3d because I just feel like 3d
is a gimmick and it can make a movie
more fun and you know it's all neat to
see like flying in 3d but
ultimately if a movie can stand it
should be able to stand in 2d and so 3d
is like an added bonus but if a movie
relies on 3d then then the movies not
good just look at the 2d version if the
2d version is great cool then 3d version
would probably also be fun if a movie is
not good in 2d s not gonna be good in 3d
do you like cats
I do like cats but I'm more of a dog
person cuz dogs have more personality
and you can tell this like there's a
collaboration like hey I need you you
needed me let's just you know be awesome
together cats kind of look at you like
you're the you know you come
home the cats like finally now
you can feed me I will let you feed me
now you may feed me I thought to say
every cat's like that when I grew up I
actually had a pretty awesome cat his
name was Martin and he was badass I
called him the boo I don't know why I
called him the boo but he was the boo
and he was a cool cat so I've had good
luck with cats and dogs in my life but I
am more of a dog person what is the main
driving force that moves you to review
media I'm gonna go out on the limb here
and I'm gonna feel I feel like what
you're asking is after doing so many
videos what how what's the driving force
that keeps me wanting to do it the good
thing about movies is that movies are
different like I'm gonna watch a movie
and that movies not actually going to be
the same as the next movie some movies
do feel repetitive sure but you can
address that sugar okay that movie was
lazy but age of Ultron is not going to
feel like Batman V Superman's although
they're both blockbusters they're not
the same movies movies they're different
they're elastic they change and so it
doesn't feel like I'm doing the same
thing over and over and over again I'm
actually talking about new
who has supported and dismissed you for
being on YouTube there are people out
there who wouldn't Frizzles okay I do
YouTube videos they wanted to I could
tell they're like Oh pat on the head
that's that's cute but don't mean now
they're all like yeah okay
let your thing that's what you do so all
in all though it's the the key people
like the best friends the my boss my
boss is actually um my family my mom my
everyone when I first started doing it
who really mattered to me they were like
oh yeah kick ass keep doing it you know
so I was I was like I know there are
people out there who want to get into
YouTube and they're just gonna run into
friction and dicks don't don't let it
sway you don't let it persuade don't let
it stop you because I'm going to use
that like nerds love this quote but when
I was in high school I was a nerd so I
loved this quote and I still love this
quote and so just remember that as
Einstein said great spirits have always
encountered violent opposition from
mediocre minds so if people want to
dissuade you from doing it it just means
they don't have the vision you have what
was your favorite movie to review I do
feel like this is different than what
was my favorite video review that I've
done my favorite movie anything that I'm
really passionate about like what the
things I like doing although they take a
lot more time they take a lot more
effort so I always have to take a deep
breath before I dive into it but I
really like like the Star Wars movies
you know like Empire Strikes Back
there's Lord of the Rings trilogy those
movies that have been out that I have
loved for many years when I get to dive
into it and do that that's always fun
because I can just be like you know what
it's a spoiler video we're just gonna
talk about how awesome this is you know
I don't have to really I'm actually with
the narrative it's not they don't have
to hold back because of like I don't
want spoilers because movies like 10 20
30 years old at that point so those are
always fun to do do you think there will
ever be a good movie based off of a
video game
I feel like now there are a couple that
I'm looking forward to them like that
could be a good movie based off of a
video game which is uncharted and the
Last of Us I feel like it's like here
here is uncharted and the Last of Us
here's the formula here's the blueprint
all you got to do is translate it into a
two-hour adventure there you go
because they're great games and they're
great stories and they're great
characters and it's all there they just
have to translate it which is difficult
to do is you have to hack it down a bit
but those are the ones that I'm
thing out for him I come huh if it's not
happening with them it's just never
happening period out of everything on
YouTube why did you pursue film
reviewing there is a myriad of things
that you can do on YouTube yeah you
could do videos on pretty much anything
but you should do videos on what you're
passionate about I'm passionate about
movies I love movies I love film I love
video games because at the time in my
life I just needed to forget about
shitty things I watched movies I watched
movies every weekend when I was in high
school so this what I know it's what I
do I've always talked about movies so I
was like hey since I always talk about
movies with my friends I just have a
camera on it's like I'm talking about
movies with my friends still my friends
and I still talk about movies even
though I talk about movies on YouTube so
do what you love talk about what you
like serious question why are you so
damn sexy and perfect I swear if you
don't answer there's no hope for the
rest of us mortals Devin was actually
submitted by my at the time girlfriend
now ex-girlfriends was just being cute
but the answer to that would be years of
practice however the person described in
that question kind of sounds like
someone you wouldn't want to lie to and
then lose I mean would you no I don't
think so
Oh too soon would you ever want to
become a professional reviewer or
journalist for Hollywood imagine what
you mean is you no way for a company in
Hollywood like a Hollywood Reporter or
something like that I mean no offense to
people who are but I like not having a
boss like everything I've done on
YouTube is to assure a couple things one
I get to do what I want talk about what
I want when I want
and do it for the fun of it did not have
a boss so that would I would have a boss
at that point so I'm fine doing it for
you guys let's just stay here if there
was a movie about your life who would
you like to play as you Keanu Keanu
Reeves I honestly don't know who I'd
want to play me in a movie I know who
I'd want to direct a movie about my life
Melo's Foreman or Milos Forman however
he died I heard it as Milos Forman I
call Emil is for me the director of One
Flew Over the Cuckoo's Nest do does
conflict really well and there's one
thing about me that you guys might not
know I could inflict with authority like
a lot I just do it's just a thing with
me so I would want him the director of
One Flew Over the Cuckoo's Nest should
direct the movie about my life why do
you not use the 1 to 10 scale of
reviewing games and movies like
other sites and critics do so don't like
being boring just one to ten just sound
so it's just one to ten but I like
sentence based things plus one to ten
like if you're like oh this movie is an
eight and then something else is an
eight point five and then something else
is like an eight people could be like
boy you do like that more than that Oh
people do that now with my sentence
based ones but I feel like it would be
worse if I did 110 plus I mean it's I
like I said look you have to be drunk to
watch it ya didn't say that do you hat
is a dog yes
let's say that oh my god we're halfway
through this Q&A this it's time for it's
the shout-out halftime show this
shout-out halftime shows brought to you
by Emma Emma she worked at the movie
theater who became the hot chick who
used to work at the movie theater who I
told her that I wish she was like Jimmy
talk about me in your videos like sure I
haven't it was a years ago so that's
Emma
Emma's cool that's right Emma you got
your shout out there's a Lannister
always pays his debts sheesh a Lannister
may always pay his debts better Jon's
pays his debts on his time which might
take years
look at this Q&A video took months are
you married like what's your personal
life like I'm not married my personal
life but I feel like I'm more boring
than people want to think that I am I
want to believe that I am ultimately I
play games I watch movies I read comic
books I hang out with friends I just I
live local I like hiking and like
that their hobbies and things I like to
do I don't do them as much as I want to
am I married no and there are certain
things in life that just aren't for
people like there are people it's like
do you want to be a chef yes or no and
some people like I just don't want to be
a chef that's kind of like me I don't
require to get married I don't require
to share my finances with someone or my
life on such a complete level with
somebody it's I just don't have enough
examples in my life to tell me or show
me that yes that's completely and
totally what I should do with my life
it's like imagine you were in Vegas
there was a game and you kept watching
this game at the point you kind of
assess there's a 90% chance like a 10%
chance you will win and live happily
ever after and a 90% chance when playing
this roulette wheel or whatever it'll be
that you lose half your like if I
saw that I'd be like
thanks but I'm gonna go over to the
blackjack tables
it's a pace so this kind of how I view
marriage like this I see people in it it
does work for some people
for myself I just don't have the drive
to do that who's your favorite film
director of all time Christopher Nolan
Christopher Nolan's like really reliable
like he come out of Christopher Nolan
moving you're probably gonna be like
that was that was pretty cool
who's your favorite Marvel superhero I
always been a spider-man guys spy man
scarlet spiders like right back there
what's your guilty pleasure movie Street
Fighter the Van Damme Street Fighter I
know a lot of words that I know more
lines in that movie then I should know
in that movie but I do it's my guilty
pleasure movie do you see all the movies
in your cinemas or do you download them
I don't like stealing so I don't torrent
movies or anything like that plus if I
were to torrent a movie and I were to
watch it on this little laptop screen it
would totally compromising xperia all
Tron if I'd just download the movie and
watch it on this little s screen gonna
be like well you know the sound wasn't
too good because it was a little space
like you got a watch in the theater for
the full of spirit take a movie for you
guys if i download it doesn't make any
sense my question is what's your
favorite video game based on a movie not
much cuz video games based off of movies
suck all the time Goldeneye was the best
so Goldeneye for the n64 there you go if
there was one moment that you wanted to
change in your life what would that be
Thanks that's like a good questions like
a deep question but ultimately I
wouldn't change anything in my life
not everything that has happened in my
life has been good or great or perfect
and some of it has been shitty
throughout life but it's kind of like
Star Trek fives a shitty movie
not many people should reference it for
many reasons but there was one scene
where Kirk was talking to Sabich I
believe his name was and Sabich was like
let me take your pain away and Kirk was
like I like my pain because it makes you
who you are and you learn from pain and
you learn it's just a trial and error
thing that's life so I wouldn't want to
change anything I feel like butterfly
effect says if I change one thing from
my past then things will be different
throughout life and maybe for the worse
so I like to think I'm an optimist where
when things are shitty you can learn
from it
then make it better so don't change
anything what are your thoughts on Sony
canceling the interview Sony canceling
the interview is kind of a tricky thing
Sony their perspectives are like we
cancelled it because all the theater
chains said they weren't going to show
it so what's the point of showing it but
I like I think there were still a couple
of theater chains out there that we're
still going to show it I feel like Sony
should have been like you know what
we're still showing it on the couple
theater chains they said they would
still show just out of principle um the
whole cancellation thing all in all it's
it's like someone makes a threat you
can't just back down like that cuz now
they're like oh you mean all we have to
do is threaten and then they back down
that's easy so I mean that kind of
invites every other to
with the United States um I remember
back in the 90s Bob Barker was getting
bomb threats they were like you know
what
cancel the prices right stop showing the
prices right or we're gonna bomb is
either your house or the studio Bob
Barker in this interview was like yeah
we're still going to show it because if
we stop then the threats win and the
people you threatened they're winning we
can't do that so they kept showing the
prices right and guess what got bombed
nothing nothing got bombed it's I feel
like this would have been that like
nothing would have gotten bombed I would
I was actually prepared on Thursday to
go and watch the interview and walk out
of the Ergo and hey nothing happened so
but it was canceled on Wednesday so I
didn't get to go on Thursday so I still
haven't seen it at a point I watch it I
will give you my review do you have a
favorite movie quote anything Yoda says
is probably gonna be among my favorite
movie quotes luminous beings are we not
this crude matter that's a good one
I've always liked that one good Oh Yoda
what movie did you like that you thought
you wouldn't like x-men first class is
among them a Rise of the Planet of the
Apes it's one of them I remember back in
the day I saw that movie identity with
John Cusack I remember walking out of it
going holy it was actually a cool
movie it might be crap now I don't know
I saw it
years upon years upon years ago but I
love that feeling when you're so
convinced movies gonna suck you walk out
going holy that just completely
surprised me I love that there's like
nothing bad it's like it's one thing to
know that you're at least strongly
suspect you're gonna like a move and you
walk out strongly like in the movie or
maybe love in the movie but it's another
thing when you're like this movie would
be and you're like oh my god it was
awesome I love that surprise do you
think the trend of MU
being spread out like The Hunger Games
and The Hobbit is a bad thing yeah you
mean like dividing the movie into two
halves sometimes it's called for like I
think Harry Potter should have done it
for the half-blood Prince because I cut
out all of the cool Tom Riddle in
half-blood Prince that was in the book
and I was like what why would you do
that so the next one they divided into
two halves and was like I'd love to have
seen that before but it's clearly now a
trend just to milk more money and again
it's it it all comes down to whether or
not the book calls for it for a movie to
be split into two I hope that's not the
norm I'd like to think it's not I just
crack my knuckles sorry about that
I can do that check us out my wrists I
don't know why it's weird to my I don't
know I'm right-handed so it makes no
sense for this hand um but yeah it's a
it's a subjective thing it really comes
down to the movie but I feel like they
should stop because it's just being it
like there's no reason to do that to a
Twilight movie are you kidding me you
could have made that seven minutes long
it would've been just as shitty with
almost 32 superhero movies coming out
until 2020 do you think the public will
get tired of them Tomica look movies are
nothing new they've been around for a
while so the fact that there's a lot
coming out now I mean I get it it's a
huge thing we all love watching them
generally speaking as long as they're
going somewhere it's not going to feel
like they're wasting our time the moment
just starts being repetitive and the
same thing over and over and over again
we're going to start we're going to
start calling for some white flags like
hey stop stop but as long as it's
getting to a point I'm cool with it if
you were a character in middle-earth
what race would you be I'd probably be a
hobbit I would stay out of the drama I
don't like drama I just wanted to have
fun and eat and be jolly and be merry
and that's at a point because everyone
wants to be a badass elf or a warrior at
a point in those Lord of the Rings
movies feels like holy I'm a hobbit
just know what you are I'm just a tall
Hobbit does it really take only three
licks to get to the center of a Tootsie
Pop I don't know if it does but if it
does if you successfully do that in
three licks of tweet that chick you will
be the most eligible bachelor ever trust
me ladies you know what I'm talking
about
what is your best memory of any video
game console when I was an L
school at a Super Nintendo and my friend
and I would have my friend spend the
night we would play contra three Turtles
and time and Mario Kart we did that all
night it's pretty awesome life
if the Joker did not exist who would be
your next favorite villain slash
antihero yeah well that'd be Darth Vader
Darth Darth Vader's like the badass of
badasses it's like the Joker he's kind
of like Batman like Joker is that side
of the spectrum like the best crazy side
of evil and Darth Vader's like the
methodical villain so it's kind of cool
that those two guys so completely
represent those sides of villainy
but yeah Darth Vader it's a beast scene
any Australian movies some Muriel's
Wedding like years ago I don't know what
that means but I saw it what's worse bad
movies doing good at the box office or
good movies doing bad at the box office
that's a good one my friend I would have
to say it's worse for good movies to do
bags like bad movies doing good cool
people are watching and if they
enjoy at least they're having fun
watching shit's getting made that
always sucks but it won't mean that good
stuff doesn't get made but if a good
movie doesn't do good in the box-office
that just means people didn't see good
stuff you know I mean like the
difference being if gets made
there's still the possibility that
people will still also go see good stuff
but if they're not seeing good stuff
that just sucks because they're not
seeing good stuff I would rather a good
movie do well what's the worst lie you
ever told someone or had someone tell
you this is a lie that I told my mom it
sounds trivial but it's she did the mom
thing where it's like I'm not mad I'm
just disappointed scream 3 came out in
theaters and I I skipped school and took
a bus to see it and then got home late I
told my mom that I took the bus after
school to go to the mall and as where I
was just at the mall hanging out after I
did all my academics but in reality I
skipped school early and watched screen
3 and my stepdad was like he totally
went in saw screen 3 you know that right
she was like no my son wouldn't lie to
me he wouldn't do that and so she
finally got out of me that I skipped
school and I went and saw screen 3 and
she was like I defended you like when
they said that's what you did I was like
no my son wouldn't do
he wouldn't lie to me I can't believe
you did that I mean I thought oh my god
talk about feeling like a small human
being that was actually the time Rebbe
was like holy
lies are actually bad like he always
know that growing up but there's always
there's going to be a time where you
fully and completely understand that
that was that time I was like I just
don't want a lot of people so I don't
lie to people and I don't like it when
people lie to me
what's your opinion on 21 Jump Street
and men in black possibly having an
official crossover movie that's awesome
are you kidding me
I'm down for that I mean I don't
know that it will work if you're looking
actually a doesn't really worry I don't
care that just sounds like a cool thing
to me I want to see that when did you
wait so long to get your hair cut I've
always waited long to get a hair like
when I was in high school or elementary
I was just that kid who I would get my
hair cut short and then I would get like
two haircuts in the school year because
it's like you get your hair cut short
you can do your hair one way and then it
grows long enough you can kind of do it
in other words like two haircuts and one
inch it and I just I like seeing what I
can do when my hair starts are growing
out you can just do more with it and you
can Shorthair Captain America or Iron
Man which side are you on
I assume you're talking about Civil War
I gotta say I am on the side of Captain
America I will always go I grew up in a
time where it wasn't like taboo it was
still fashionable to be kind of
patriotic and like now it's almost
like frowned upon I really patriotic you
love a country that but I grew up
in a time where that was like a cool
thing to be a good thing to do so I am
like that um and I but I will always
take freedom for the people over control
that the government's doing so yeah
Captain America all the way fight for
freedom and and that concludes my
second part of my Q&A thank you very
much guys for being patient about that
show my god I'm really sick you have
more patients than me and I love you for
that cuz I'm not a patient person at all
I just I'm not but thank you guys very
much for for being really cool fans and
getting me to it dislike 670,000 now I
did my first Q&A at 500,000 oh my god
but yeah we're like on on our way up
there to a million maybe and that's just
a cool thing that and that's why I'm
like no I don't want to work for a
company that does row
ports in Hollywood I don't want to boss
I'm doing fine here with you guys we are
having fun generally speaking there are
a couple of dick bags who comment shitty
things yeah but generally speaking we're
having a lot of fun here if you want
more fun just outside the videos you can
follow me at Jeremy John's it's a
shameless Twitter plug but I mean
there's no relevance whatsoever it's
like it's not like I'm doing
groundbreaking they're like
world-changing things I'm just just more
fun just quirky things that I say so
maybe you'll have fun there to last good
look at Darth Vader and Scarlet Spider
and Metal Gear Rex and Nick it's now
know if you can see naked snake at this
point you kind of like moved off frame
hold on yeah are you getting everything
yeah like so this thing is such a bass I
love this is huge and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more